well as the weather warms up metro  police have just a few tips to keep in  mind when you're hiking  the air support team says the biggest  thing to remember in the outdoors is to  tell somebody  where you're going and we recommend  not going alone take somebody with you  some of the rescues we have  people are out there alone they didn't  tell anybody where they go somebody  finds a car  and we have to do a massive search in  addition to the rescue we later have to  perform  some other things to consider are just  some be sure to check the weather  take some food and water with you maybe  even some overnight supplies  a light source and a fully charged phone  if you need to call someone